the Russian officials continue to mock
the Biden team's weak diplomacy with one
Kremlin Diplomat slamming the quote hype
around the Griner case it comes as
greiner's coach says there's double
standards at play arguing that if it
were LeBron James imprisoned overseas
he'd already be back home here with
three action hosts of The Buck and Clay
show Buck Sexton and Clay Travis thanks
so so much for joining us uh here clay
let's start with you uh what do you what
do you make of this story
well I think there's a double standard
at play and thanks for having us on the
double standard is if Donald Trump were
president he'd already have Brittany
Greiner back uh and that is because you
look at what happened with the UCLA
basketball players who were arrested in
China Trump got personally involved with
ASAP Rocky in Sweden Trump got
personally involved and we wouldn't have
the war in Europe at all I don't think
that Russia would have invaded Ukraine
if Trump were president but if this had
happened regardless I think Trump would
have gotten involved and he'd have
gotten Brittany Greiner back and if
Brittany Greiner has regrets and one
would be traveling potentially with
drugs in Russia she may also regret as
she said in the letter voting for Joe
Biden because Donald Trump would have
had her back more than Biden has I feel
quite confident in that
yeah Buck I think Donald Trump was able
to bring home 55 prisoners Ambassador
Robert O'Brien a secretary of state Mike
Pompeo involved in those and uh Trump
brought home 55 detainees around the
world he he knew how to get it done
well we just have to add foreign policy
and clout on the foreign stage to the
areas of just utter failure of the Biden
Administration everyone should remember
Joe Biden was brought on to the Obama
presidential ticket to be the foreign
policy guy and if you remember the eight
years I know you do Jason of the Obama
Administration it was a foreign policy
disaster everything everywhere pretty
much got worse so there's nothing that's
surprising about Joe Biden being
incapable of negotiating a deal to get
not just this America by the way I want
every American home from Russia I want
Brittany Greiner home I want the other
Americans including Paul Whalen home
from Russia but the by Administration
doesn't have what it takes to negotiate
this deal obviously doesn't have the
kind of personal gravitas I think with
Vladimir Putin that would help move the
needle and the Russians know this which
is why by the way there's now this rumor
floating around that maybe the guy that
the movie Lord of War Victor about
Remember Nicholas Cage play that arms
dealer that may be the trade that is
offered here so the guy who was known as
The Merchant of death may be traded for
Brittany Greiner that was reported on uh
by Forbes earlier today so that would be
quite a move but from the bite
Administration would it be surprising I
don't think so
yeah Clay I mean there's just just this
air this Aura of incompetence that
permeates throughout I mean you have
staff that are just kind of diving for
the exits it's it's kind of sad to watch
you even have people that are active
Democrats being quoted and talked about
in Politico and other Publications
saying the guy's a fool
well I I think it's telling buck and I
were talking about on the radio show
earlier today Barack Obama didn't
endorse Joe Biden until he'd already
wrapped up the nomination and he also
chose in 2016 to expressly pass by his
vice president and instead support
Hillary Clinton's presidential campaign
so it's not just an aura of incompetence
it is incompetence Joe Biden's the worst
American president so far in a hundred
years and all those people who were
upset about Mean Tweets all those people
who told us that they had to be on the
right side of History guess what they
voted for Joe Biden they're definitively
on the wrong side of History whether
it's foreign policy whether it's the
Border whether it's crime whether it's
inflation every single thing that Joe
Biden touches turns to craft the bite us
touch is real and it's the exact
opposite of the Midas touch
yeah you know Buck uh we knew this right
I mean when the guy has nearly 50 years
of experience in Washington DC he didn't
just suddenly surprise people in the
last 18 months I mean they they knew
what they were getting and what they
were buying and now they're having to
live with it oh I mean clay said it well
you look at all the areas of failure you
actually never have the time to really
work through them on any show honestly
including our own uh you find yourself
just talking about not only the promises
that were not kept Joe Biden said he was
going to unify the country last summer
he was talking about people who didn't
want to get the mandatory vaccine like
they were some kind of terrorist group
Joe Biden has failed consistently on
everything that he has touched but let's
remember even Democrats until about five
minutes ago knew this guy was a sub
mediocrity and a loser he had run
numerous times for president before and
was never even really taken seriously as
a candidate but in the pandemic year
when America was being told that you
know basically we were all going to die
and it was all Trump's fault we needed a
grandfather figure the media played this
whole thing out and now we have the
exact candidate the Trojan Horse for the
left and the incompetent buffoon that we
warned America about Clay did I did you
did and that's who we've got and now the
Democrats are realizing they can't sell
that one in the midterms or for
re-election hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else